there's a moment in Doctor Strange 2
where zombie Benedict Cumberbatch goes
back in time to tell America Chavez that
she just needed to believe in herself
all along there's no progression to the
characters especially if they're female
or from a minority it patronizes women
because it basically makes them out to
be incapable of ever dealing with any
challenge they can't overcome anything
they are perfect as they are that is the
running theme when it comes to these
female characters and it's such an
unhealthy message to send to people take
an hour of personal opinions out of the
equation that it's like trying to make
out that women are just perfect at
everything which you know we're all
human none of us are perfect it's
teaching people that you shouldn't need
to strive to improve yourself you
shouldn't need to struggle and when you
come across challenges or adversity the
rest of the world just needs to accept
that you're amazing the way you are it
used to be such a much more inspiring
message that movies give you about the
power of self-improvement